how special is it for you matthew to be
with mike man
you know what i mean to be in this
position right now very very um
special it's just a blessing you're
living your dream right now matthew yeah
uh there's there's more like to come
[Music]
hey we're here at the mike tyson hop
boxing show i have one of my favorite
favorite people here already i have
matthew fernandez here with his friend
charlie and henry i'm very excited no
we're super excited come on guys
over here
let's get it get it
hey
i looked i love that you brought that
clap
one more time
matthew matthew we love you brother
i mean talk to us charlie about matthew
man talk to us
matthew
dm'd me
ten days ago
and
immediately i was like i got to meet you
like he was so inspiring you know
forgive my ignorance i'm
i'm a square what is dmt so i know dm
[Laughter]
direct message on on instagram he
messaged me all right and three hours
later i pulled up at his house and i
just wanted to ask him one question
it was like matthew what's your dream
like you're so inspiring but like what's
your dream because matthew has cerebral
palsy
but the doctors told him he wouldn't he
would be a vegetable
and i mean no
like yeah he proved them all wrong and
his mindset is proof like you can
overcome but he has two dreams his dream
is to be able to walk for the first time
on his own
and the second dream because he's really
inspired by nipsey hustle
i was like okay if you can make a lot of
money to be able to afford
the treatments and the physical therapy
and the equipment to be able to walk how
would you make your money he said i want
to have a clothing line like nipsey
hustle
well
last night his clothing line came out
and he sold
300 000 in the first 12 hours damn come
on come on matthew
yeah but um what gave you that thought
that's them what gave you that thought
the clothing line yeah what gave you
that thought when what was it about nick
rehustle
that gave you that inspiration uh how he
helped
his community
like um uh how he helped
like the people um
strive for success
and uh
yeah that
that's what i love about him
i think that's cool you kind of brought
that up pretty profound mike because you
did you because you are right money is
money but the thought that you have in
your mind that you want to manifest is
is priceless right mike incredible
matthew believe it or not even though
like he has a hard time walking and
talking like in school a b student he
went homecoming queen he went to college
like he went to elect like very smart
like smarter than
i told i told him you're probably
smarter than all of us in this room
and that's why like when he went to
design his first designs he pulled out a
piece of paper
and the things he started designing were
genius i'm like because i i've done
clothing my whole life like merged and i
was like this is some of the best stuff
i've seen
and this is within a few days of meeting
them and i'm like okay i think he was
meant for this so what do you tell him
about this
talent that he possessed you know you
seem to be his mentor what do you tell
him about this talent that he possessed
like
when i saw what he was capable of i was
like okay like he's fully capable of
running a business no doubt
and what he's going to be able to do
with it
because now like like he the the problem
is like with cerebral palsy he needs to
get his muscles strong but
he lives in a vertical apartment and
there's nowhere to walk in the apartment
in the neighborhood he lives in he can't
practice walking outside it's very
dangerous like somebody
you know got killed you know a few doors
down
and
i talked to his mom and she was like it
would just be so nice to be able to live
in a flat home
with in a neighborhood with sidewalks
and so
he had that motivation and like i think
there was something really divine about
it like whatever he channeled and
manifested
he manifested
us into his life
and now
they're going to be able to move into
that home he's going to be able to have
the equipment he's going to be able to
overcome and be able to take those first
steps
you know
in all due respect you know no reason
what does he know about god
oh man
i'll let him speak on that but from what
i've seen
this man's got a direct line
well it appears that way to me too so i
want to know what's his experience with
this
you know i'm not i'm trying to learn i'm
not trying to teach right now mm-hmm
i think his brother could probably speak
a little bit better you might get over
in the seat man i told you to get in the
seat man
that's awesome but speaking about you
charlie i mean you've
you've been inspired you're like you're
not you're not your typical
well actually you were an average joe
who are you i'll say the first thing
i'll say is a dreamer um
and i just always believe that like
everything is possible like not anything
but
um i used to manage two chains for ten
years i discovered two chains when he
was titty boy
um it was a titty boy titty boy that was
his rapper name before he was two champs
like in the country of georgia
but i used to manage artists um
recording artists from atlanta i had one
of the biggest hip-hop firms um
and
at the height of my career
i was diagnosed with a brain tumor and i
was 300 pounds
and
like
facing death
i was just like
okay well
you start really thinking about your
dreams when you're about to die the
dreams you didn't accomplish because
because all i knew was
i knew how to make money
but i settled because when i was little
all i wanted to do was be an athlete
like that was my dream like i literally
have nightmares where i would die in the
in my
in my sleep and my thought when i would
wake up is like
dang i didn't get to experience what it
was like to have my dream come true
because i buried that athletic dream
because i was always overweight my whole
life
so i said all right i'm gonna be a
businessman and you know my business
took off as a young man i was soldier
boys cameraman
manage you know these recording artists
but then i was like you know what
i want to go back i want to go back to
my original dream
and and that's when i got really
connected with god
and i needed a miracle
and within a year and a half of me
retiring from my business
i
i ran
five marathons i did an ironman
i
i reversed my brain tumor
and
the biggest nike commercial of all time
was uh dedicated to me to colin
kaepernick commercial i was in it
uh nike named it after me it was called
dream crazy i made a fan made nike
commercial that inspired nike to create
that film
and it was all about dreams
so all my dreams came true
and that's what made me at that point
say
i want to dedicate my life to making
other people's dreams come true because
i got everything
and that's what leads me to
matthew
yeah we have uh we have uh his brother
too man
which what's your take on everything
that's been that's been going what did
you take on this guy that you don't know
he don't know and they have this bond
i think it's beautiful
i think uh energy attracts energy
and good people attract good people
and charlie's been a huge blessing for
our life because he just popped in
on my mother's birthday
and he's all like yo let's manifest your
dreams man and it's so beautiful because
you know when when
my mom takes care of my brother 24 7.
and uh
this is like her dream come true to have
like a whole army backing up matthew
because you know we all want matthew to
live a fruitful life we want matthew to
run we want matthew to have friends we
want matthew to experience all the
things that i've experienced as a
brother right
but unfortunately
you know for 22 years it's been him
alone with the family so now having
whether charlie and the whole dream team
pulling up
man there's thousands of people
supporting matthews you know saying hey
you're not alone and that's energy bro
it's all energy
that's my take on that mm-hmm
it's it's really it's really interesting
how like people are like reflections of
you
like when i met matthew i didn't know
much about him
but when i pulled up
and started asking him
and i saw how much he loved hip-hop and
i was like wow that was like a
reflection of me like because i was a
big part of my life
and then when i saw like what is with
his family and like his mother like
believes in all the metaphysical and
eastern medicines and healing and i'm
like that's a big part of me too and i'm
like it's no secret why we're here why
we attract why we find the people that
are in life our lives because
i mean i think we're just like a
reflection of each other and that's why
like these divine things happen where
one plus one could equal
three or a thousand instead of two
the product of our um
surrounding uh error
generation slaves to it
yeah slave state you're right i do
remember conversating you one time mike
i don't know if you remember this but
we're in uh
we're in jacksonville florida we're
getting ready uh we're getting we're
getting ready to jump on the on the
plane on the private plane
and i remember you're just talking about
life about society it's like why do you
got to get married now is it because
society's telling you like you know what
i'm saying once you sit down just like
no that's kind of programmed a little
bit
a little bit a lot of it
listen whistle program i always look at
this show about how much i control uh
how much control of uh phone and handle
over us and everything so i made a
promise to myself i only use my phone on
mondays
once a week i use my phone because i saw
the process and i see the process of my
it's so bad my son had the television in
the computer playing
and if i turned off the television hey
hey what are you doing he's not even
looking at it but
it's that that energy that vibration
that he has to have it and then one day
they're gonna turn it all off and we're
gonna and it's gonna be anarchy out here
you know how you know how mad
[ __ ] gonna be when they don't
got that phone this [ __ ] right here and
that
that
computer
having uh close death encounters charlie
i imagine that's kind of what you you've
been through close death encounters
right mike yeah but um that's his um
harmony
oh no life is the willingness to die you
know because we're going to do it anyway
so and we always um
we fight it we fight it we never we
never give in to it we fight we were
born to give into it but still we fight
that's that's the sin we have in us
fighting god mm-hmm you think you're
fighting something bad that's hurting
you but you're fighting god death is god
you're not gonna get let go with it
let's go with the flow go with it
charlie is that something this is that
something that you do do you have the
same philosophy as mike somebody that
you had a tumor bro
you want you want to describe that a
little bit i mean how
how bad that was like i remember it was
this day because like
my whole life being on a diet from age
eight i'd always like starve myself but
like food is a lot like breathing really
i starve myself because i see what it
did to my family all my family's obese
my sister died of obesity about 500
pounds heartburn
so all my fat all my family a very old
beast you know you know big country
[ __ ] from the south eating all
that bad [ __ ] yeah and that's my family
that's just my family they can't stop it
i'm highly educating my brother the
doctor smart and he still can't um he's
a great man still can't stop putting
stuff in his mouth mm-hmm
and i still struggle with it oh i do too
but um i'd rather die than be like i
would starve myself to death
right sometimes i go um and i'm a muslim
i'm not a dedicated mother but sometimes
i will go on my fast not for 30 but 45
days not even for god but for vanity my
weight but since it's the ramadan that
gives me a reason to do this yeah you
know do you do you feel
what does it teach you mike
the fasting it teaches me that i can
endure more than anyone
do you feel cleaner when you come out of
like a like ramadan like
30 x days of doing i feel like i feel
like i took the most powerful drugs i
ever took in my life by just being clean
yeah because you know um why so why is
it listening no listen listen listen
brother um do you know um your fat needs
a certain amount of brain to function
and when it's when you're going fast
that that extends out that that's that
meat that fat and you start talking and
[ __ ] start happening you start seeing
[ __ ] yeah the mind has a lot of fat the
mind works better the fatter it is the
better it works the more you fast the
less fat is in the brain
and less saturday brandon you start
getting seeing [ __ ] and hallucinating
and then passing out and may die
so the people that said fat is bad
no fat has this place in life that's why
it's here
yeah
everything's here on this planet has
this place in life how we know about the
toad how we know about all these special
medicines it's taller than ever right
yeah it's crazy mike it's almost it's so
simplified for us because we know that
the medicine is on earth yeah but let me
talk about this have charlie ever used
any um medicine
like um plant medicine or animal
medicine like how i reverse my brain
tumor was literally just with plants
like i went about them i went vegan the
crazy thing i experienced with it
really like the the foundation of
of me solving my issue with food
addiction and just like
my my brain tumor and all that was i
just asked myself a simple question
i said
if you are what you eat
is what i'm eating dead or alive
and i just started looking at food as if
like all right if i eat like a
a cliff bar you know that's vegan but
it's dead it could sit there for like
three years like it's just not vibrating
i know my brother can actually i mean my
wife was talking and we were saying
let's look at the one how long could
sometimes i don't i'll be fasting for
i'm not i haven't eaten nothing and
somebody go to the bathroom i take a
[ __ ] this long i said now where so i go
like this to my wife that's it
i go to my wife i said baby i haven't
eaten in 25 days where did this come
from how long does it stay in your
system how can all that stay in your
system without you eating that's crazy
so many microscopic things that we i
guess there's a lot of things that we
haven't discovered but one thing i will
say that we have discovered has been
medicine yeah it keeps it keeps
improving
you know it keeps improving this is
interesting let me explain about um
venereal disease they started off in
biblical times as rashes
and so
rap this rash but people were dirty back
then they had a lot of germs but once
they got um enlightened on cleaning
they stopped losing the the thing was
scared the rash
was scared that was going to be ext
extinct yeah so it went from a rash and
it went into our venereal
just for protection a lot of protection
up there we can't get them no way we
gotta shoot some stuff in us to get them
so they want to survive so they went
into us in our vaginal
areas i saw through the pee hole
probably got through there i'll do our
paws
listen um what's killing us now is time
and time is invisible it's right here a
lot of particles are coming out and this
is how we're done we can't even see our
death godly
you know how much we getting poisoned
right this minute we're getting poisoned
by by god's dust
we don't even know light up a joint man
let's make it right
here
we're born to die so we got to pick a
way that we die we die in peace so we
die in
chaos that was deep that was that was
actually deep remember um after your
training you talked to dre and i and you
were talking about you're born losing
already oh absolutely as the time goes
by as time goes by we lose our friends
we lose our hair
we lose our teeth we lose our sexual
desire
and we wonder why the hell i'm here
anymore everybody i love is dead
my grand i love my grandkids and my kids
and everything but they don't
they i love them you know but they don't
unders i don't understand them that's
what these old guys say i love my wife i
love my kids but i don't understand them
right right and they say you know god
takes you the heavens take you exactly
so having to know that right is just
you have to make most of your life
live your life like there is let me
explain something the only thing that
keeps us in check the life all of us
cycles and everybody that expiration
date
that's we never forget that
we forget everything else like we get
this number we forget when our parents
call we never forget the possibility of
that expiration date
that's the only thing that keeps us in
perspective makes us work hard for our
kids until that expiration date comes
you know once you get conscious of the
expiration date you become a totally
different person you look at life
totally different right you're looking
about what you can leave before you go
exactly you think you had those thoughts
mike when uh you need to toad revealed
that or you think you already had that
the total review revealed that
the only thing i thought about
this um um before the toe was my dick
um
the toes really put that in check
you know
and i used to be scared i used to pray a
thousand times before i take and now i
can't look i look for i take it too much
i you know i just have to take it
sometimes you just you get scared mine
before you do it huh you have i'm
looking for the first time the first ten
times i was scared but now i look so
much forward forward to do it i do it
all now are y'all talking about the
venom oh yeah okay i'm getting ready to
do the scorpion venom i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do the white cobra venom god i'm
gonna do the centipede
you guys let me in on next remember that
first time i did the toad with you mike
i'll tell i'll be honest with you i was
[ __ ] bricks that night this
listen listen the first time i did it in
that room there right and i thought you
know i'm much yeah give me this [ __ ]
right when i did that
and i i died oh these white
[ __ ] killed me i stopped trying
to prove something these white
[ __ ] i died
and i said and then i woke up and the
first thing i said when i woke up
where's my wife
because once you take the toll you don't
think about your kid you know you just
you facing the the divine elements
and it's scary because it's like this
there's things that all of us have that
we keep secretly this we let somebody
know
we'd be shamed you know what
the tote opens it up and you feel like
all your secrets are let out no word no
worthy secret you ever have
imagine that frightening feeling
imagine that feeling if you imagine that
feeling
your friends know every secret you ever
had since the day you were born
or every mistake you made from a human
perspective
imagine somebody knowing all that that's
what the toe dude makes you totally
oblivious
to frightening at the same time
and then when it's over they say no
you're crying and happy and can't wait
to do it again
it has that effect on you you know
they've been here before us when you
really think about the specifics of who
we are we can't even tell you who we are
yeah if we can tell you who we were at
this stage of our life we'd be some
limited [ __ ] i don't know who i
am you don't know you know we could make
up who we are yeah i'm a fly [ __ ]
making money doing else i'm an honest
guy do this i work hard we can say these
things but we don't know who we are
where we came from
you know i think
you guys are probably you know what i
mean it's a trip what he's saying but
he's right dude when you do it it's like
you get a reality check that
it's just like man i thought life was
about this
no and it strips imagine there's life
about things that the mind wants
especially because look you see he have
all of us loving him
even though we don't want to show this
how god allows us to show our humbleness
and our passion
and compassion
you know we're all [ __ ] we got some
stuff about us that you know we do that
you know not cool probably in society
but
when it comes down to life this is what
it is we all have to take care of one of
them so you know
madden he was a prick his family the
prickle he's in the [ __ ] way i can't
go out now to this [ __ ] here and
all this [ __ ] i can't [ __ ] this [ __ ]
because he's here and uh imagine they
were like no there's people out there
like that yeah you know how easy it is
to be selfish so easy to be selfish that
it is to be kind and it's easy to be
kind right so you know how he is twice
and ten times easy to be selfish
and he gets nothing but love
oh yeah matthew made our family way
closer we're a tribe for sure yes that
makes it better 100
my children make my life better
you know it wasn't for my children i'm
an animal
my wife and my family without them i'm a
[ __ ] i have no self dignity no self
expect i would do anything
but you know my family in love
totally um put all that piece of [ __ ]
activity out the window
yeah
now recovering from that tumor charlie
and obviously losing 110 pounds to like
literally getting a second chance at
life
you know your goal now is is to help a
million people right
with pretty much a million dreams and
obviously matthew is one of them
you know are you are you like that
go-getter that finds those inspirational
stories and you try to turn those into
uh
you know how does that work because
i would love to be part of that live
where's the line
man we like we're launching a tour in
like eight days like we have a we have a
tour bus called the dream machine and we
literally like when covet hit i sold my
house
i moved into the bus
and i hit the road because they told us
like everybody go inside
my whole life like
rules are important but if i see a rule
i'm like i'm go like people need help
like let's go like people's dreams are
dying if they got to sit in their house
all day and so i hit the road and
like i got all these amazing people that
we call them all dream hitchhikers
everybody here i picked up
like my best friend from middle school
like i called
langford right here
my best friend
big time
big time auditor at the fdic
works full-time
i call him up i said hey i'm on tour
i need my boy
he said how long you need me on the road
i said give me three days
he's been on the road with us for
13 months
and he just retired from the fdic
yesterday he's full-time dream machine
cfo every single person here left their
corporate jobs moved them from the uk
corporate job like everybody's a dreamer
because we're inspired by people like
matthew so we're launching a tour we're
giving away
a million dollars
in 45 days
of our cryptocurrency usd but like of
the dreamer token so every day we got 22
thousand dollars to give away to help
people with their dreams to keep the
dream alive so
i mean
i'm going to spend my whole life doing
this i'm gonna i'm gonna do everything i
can to be
you know
just a blessing i would love at my
funeral one day to
have a stadium full of people dreams i
made come true of course charlie how old
are you 33. you're 33 or 80 88 88 yeah
yeah
that's crazy man
[Music]
what's up everyone the 2021 nfl season
is here and draftkings is all of the
week's number one's action and if you
didn't know draftking is the official
daily fantasy partner of the nfl it's
easy to get started just sign up using
your code hop boxing then you make your
first deposit and after you do those two
things you will get your shot at a one
million dollar top prize anytime i get a
shot at a million dollars i know i take
it see draftkings.com baby for the
detail so remember download the
draftkings app now use code hotbox to
make your first deposit of at least five
dollars get your shot at a million bucks
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftking.com for details
[Music]
you got that second shot of life man
because obviously you're in the music
industry you want to damn grammy for
crying out loud mm-hmm
why you know what i'm saying like i'm
curious to understand that exit
and uh and you know what i'm saying when
you reach the top like that
so
for me
like leaving the music industry wasn't
wasn't very hard i had a
successful business
but
like i said mike like i'm a dream i'm
crazy like my mom when i told her i'm
gonna retire she said how you gonna make
money because i'm telling her i'm gonna
be an athlete but she's looking at her
son who's 300 pounds
you know like like what you mean you're
going to be an athlete
i'm like i figured out something's going
to bless me
and
i just i just left it wasn't difficult
like i believe
that we're
created to create and we can create
anything like we created a dream it was
it was effort like i don't have that
many followers on instagram
but
it was effort
it wasn't i didn't get matthew 300 000.
it was just i used my platform and asked
a few hundred thousand people to help
and they helped
so it's like what happens with that
money matthew
and his family they really want to get
into a home yeah you were telling me
that yeah they really want to get a
wheelchair accessible van because bless
his mom's heart mom dad everybody they
got to pick them up carry them up these
days
my um stepmother come in we said she was
an old woman 79 so we had to um
build a chair in uh
on the on the stairs dennis what's that
banister on the stairway mm-hmm and they
take her up the stairs yeah yeah
and this and it's got to be tough
because you know pops
he has his own business
but mom she has to take care of him
every day so it's just it's just a tough
situation so you know i'm one of those
guys to believe nothing's impossible to
somebody who tries mm-hmm everything's
hard yeah everything's gonna be hard the
situation is hard so you have to expect
everything to be hard we have to be
comfortable being uncomfortable
you know that's just what it is
yeah so with matthew matthew being able
to be in a a better place like one of
the manifestations i have right now is
like a big fashion mogul like a
virgil or a kanye reach out and be like
always possible there's nothing listen
mm-hmm and after i like to listen i come
from the [ __ ] sewage of [ __ ] bro
listen nobody in my neighborhood make me
up it's all animals we hurt people
we steal from each other
we do all that stuff and i'm saying
nobody would ever think a guy like me
would make it
either
they diagnosed me as [ __ ]
i'm mostly on my show
yeah they said i was [ __ ] can you
believe that they put me on thought
thing and [ __ ]
and it helped me
with you more aggressive
they put me on thor thing you know they
thought they didn't call me like no
but they got me hurt
it worked different on me damn
so happy that we i wanted to put um
matthew on the show so bad
because we have so many hundreds of you
hundreds of million viewers i wanted
them to see him i appreciate you so much
for that uncle mike i don't worry about
that
yeah charlie charlie so what's what's
the overall goal for you though like for
you know obviously i know you want to
start this you know you man a lot of a
lot of your colleagues here and they uh
they quit their job do you know what i'm
saying
like is it just to continue to keep
helping like going on tour and continue
to helping like the the people that
really need the help that's it man like
matthew is a testament you know this is
what we want to do like
like
i realized like in my life i was
surrounded by a lot of bad people when i
was trying to make things about me
like people steal from me accountants
all sorts of bad business partners
family members people would take
advantage of me because i'm really nice
but then when i made the mission
bigger about other people and i got up
off of me
i got surrounded by the best people in
the world family happened to me brother
yeah same thing
and it's like once you once you taste
what it feels like
to to like like lessons you saw a custom
being with filth and then when you with
something of a clean nature you say hey
this ain't right this is wrong you don't
even feel
comfortable yeah because it's that
programming we don't even know that
we're being programmed we're around
something so much we don't even know
there's another side to it
and then when i experience this other
side
where
all this magic and manifestation and god
just blessing miracles i'm like i can't
ever go back like i'm gonna sail off
into the sunset doing this i mean after
you see matthew's mother and father
at our dreamer house last night just
crying they're just watching
like every 15 minutes 10 000 is coming
in
all right listen i've been to places um
i've seen children with um
that are function talking to a machine
with just nobody it's the head
and they're still alive
you know so i'm pretty
when i see a situation that i'm very
humbled
very humbled and i want to be involved
with situations like that
because it shows me who i really am that
i'm nothing if i can't listen if i get
all this money and i'm a big fly ass
[ __ ] if i can't help them who the [ __ ]
am i
who really am i am am i some superstar
really and i can't help somebody like
that
and his situation and i love his family
and i can't help him
yeah you know that's not no superstar
man this says a lot about you because me
coming from the entertainment industry
it's not always like that right well
i mean
there's a lot of people i know in
entertainment
i've been listening i'm older than you
i've seen more than you in the industry
okay that is all about survival in there
that's just all about survival it's not
about helping nobody the lsu my team and
you're doing what i tell you to say
you know this is a control mechanism and
if they're crew against everybody else's
crew that's right you know
and that's just how it is and then
boxing's the same way the people that
you trust the most and the people that
you invest the most time in disappoint
you the most
so that's why sometimes yeah because we
because we're afraid guys like me and
him we're successful but we always give
our power to someone else
you know because we think they're going
to take care of us on the level because
that's what they said
and they do different
yeah you know until you made this move
right here this is the first time you
just done that you did
initiative you know i mean like nah this
is the first time i did some my own
initiatives
that's why i mean i really
i appreciate you man i appreciate you
because you allowing
matthew and myself to come on when you
interview the biggest people in the
world but this
this right here like i think matthew in
a year could be one of those biggest
people in the world you don't see this
it's not like his man
his brother helped me
interview the biggest people in the
world mm-hmm
you know so as you know
it's just put you know pushing it
forward man it's special yeah how
special is it for you matthew to be you
know to be to be with mike man
you know what i mean to be in this
position right now
um very very um
special it's just a blessing
are you living you're living your dream
right now matthew uh
yeah
uh there's there's more
like uh to come and
you guys this is just um
this is crazy like
yeah like oh um all these
like these wonderful people even um
charlie he
and take your time brother we'll wait he
overwhelmed
that's what love does to people it
overwhelms people that's cool amigos
uh miguel michael
how how is this my house is
you know your little brother man what
he's going through right now how cool is
it for you man it's super cool
super super cool
um it's a major major blessing i mean
you know since birth he was gonna be a
twin you know but one of the twins uh
passed away in my mother's belly in six
months of pregnancy so they had to
perform a c-section
and matthew was pronounced dead
so they resuscitated matthew
he was one pound and a half he was
living my parents were going in and out
of the hospital he was an incubator for
six months
had over 16 surgeries said he was going
to be a vegetable he wasn't going to be
able to walk talk or any of that stuff
my mother took him off of western
medicine
and she took the holistic route we got
into meditation yoga
sound healing all these herbal medicines
and stuff and he started talking he
started strengthening his legs he's just
a fighter all around he puts me to shame
the stuff that this guy goes through
he's a real warrior here i'm just here
to be like yo i'm here to lift you up
bro
you know so
seeing him like achieve his dreams is
probably like one of my biggest dreams
you know as a as an older brother
and yeah man it's super overwhelming
all of everybody's supporting our family
is like the greatest thing in the world
you know the prayers have been answered
and god has just
you know opened the gates of abundance
and everything's flowing
so man it's it's a strong feeling
brother henry well i just want to know
one more thing before this is um
done i i want you to look at all these
people
and
what you want to say to them
they they're um very very um
like um wonderful that
they're like a blessing for my life
and
i love you guys i love my heart we love
you too with all our heart
my man's over here crying
brother
hey chill have fun
good relax
this is all family bro this is all love
over here no strangers in here
that's what's up what about you charlie
what uh you want you want to you want to
close it out man you want to give up
let's see let the world know who you
about and what you're doing brother man
look right in these people's eyes
cameras please all i can ask for anybody
watching is
support matthew's dream
let's make this let's make this one of
the
most inspirational men in the world
because he is let's give him stages
let's give him platforms wear his
clothes everybody in here right now
squaring his clothing thank you so much
for
you know supporting mike and your love
brother this is all about matthew a part
of the family thank you everyone check
out my little brother's website violet's
our kind of purple.com we got a rock in
the merch
he designed it you know uncle mike's
rocking it charlie's rocking it
well you guys just watched an episode of
hot boxing with mike tyson i'm your
co-host triple c aka henry cejudo
and mike tyson i'm so glad to have my
guest here matthew and charlie and mike
thank you very much for the evening
everyone
[Music]
you